[Applaudissements]
nathalie thompson
je vous repose la question encore une
fois devant la caméra vous êtes sûr de
ne pas vouloir faire appel à un avocat
on n'est pas besoin vous est suspecté
d'avoir participé à l'enlèvement de léo
newman son commentaire non demain tout
ça est forcément un horrible malentendu
on ne peut pas savoir si c'est une
revendication terroriste pour des
raisons politiques ou une simple
extension un jeune homme léo newman a
été mis de force dans une valise par un
grand masque et la police de new york a
affiché quatre suspects
katherine newman je n'arrive pas à
imaginer les preuves que vous traversez
ces jours ci une mère qui aime sortie et
qui veut qu'on le lui
[Musique]
on était piégé pourquoi nous je sais pas
pour toi qu'est-ce qu'on a en commun on
est tous britanniques
ils en étaient tous à new york en les os
et c'est qu'il a pris franchement est-ce
qu'on a des têtes de kidnappeurs ça
occulte est kidnappée
la vôtre
sans preuve de notre innocence j'ai bien
peur que les dégâts soient irréparable
chevet de tout danger
vous êtes sûr de savoir ce que vous
faites mais je peux plus reculer on ne
me trouvera pas crédible dans mon rôle
de mère
je suis pdg dans un premier temps
discrétion jusqu'à ce qu'il n'y ait plus
d'options première pole tout notre manu
sauf que je ne me souviens pas du
chapitre où il est question du
kidnapping d'un enfant
[Musique]
de la communication à qui l'on demande
justement de communiquer en échange de
la libération dynamique offenser
personne demande uniquement de la vérité
il s'enfonce un peu plus chaque minute
aujourd'hui encore une chance que les
gens comprennent ce qu'on a fait jusqu'à
maintenant
vous avez sous-estimer ces suspects
depuis le début
[Musique]
la vérité va bien finir par se savoir